We don't have to have fast food workers,
we don't,
we don't have to have people who work
shit
jobs,
we don't have to,
which Si to figure out how to
restructure society.
So everybody somehow another plays a
part has something to contribute,
something to share.
I mean that's what a real society is
supposed to be like.
I've given you some coconuts.
You get me some fish,
you know,
we make a deal and you do it back and
forth and left and right,
and when there's nothing to contribute,
then you start looking.
The president needs to give us jobs.
We need jobs.
So instead of something to contribute,
you just find something to do with your
time and then it becomes about doing
that more than it becomes about finding
something to contribute.
So society gets wrapped around becoming
a part of a machine society instead of
becoming a bunch of individuals that are
expressing themselves in unique ways and
everybody's sort of borrows and shares
and sells this and you sell that.
And we all sort of figured out how we
can contribute in a society.
We got sidetracked and diverted into
these boxes that they call companies and
corporations and we got stuck into these
containers.
They go cubicles or offices and we've
got forced into this system,
so our time,
instead of it being invested in making
pottery or or fixing cars or doing
something where you have a passion or
you have some sort of a connection to
instead of that you've sold your life to
sit in a box and work for a machine,
an uncaring machine that demands
productivity,
doesn't understand you.
It doesn't want to understand you.
It has a bunch of very strict things in
order to keep the humor at a minimum in
the office,
just in case one fuckheads says some
stupid sex jokes that gets him sued and
they have to give somebody a million
dollars.
So get it together and this is your life
now.
No natural behavior.
Everybody's wearing clothes.
They don't want to where everybody's
showing up and doing something they
don't want to do.
They have no connection to.
That's the problem with our society and
then what's the reward for all this
stuff?
Go on,
get a big TV,
go home,
you're going to get a shiny belt buckle,
you're going to get a nice purse.
You're going to wear shoes that you
couldn't afford last week.
You got to get that dream car and every
week we're chasing down this new object
and every week trying to fill this hole
in this,
this,
this sad shadow of a life that we've
been left with after work that you work
eight to whatever,
the hours a day plus commuting and then
you'll like this and that's your life.
That's your real fucking life.
All that other stuff is not your life
anymore.
All that other stuff is work and most of
us have committed to that.
I know you've been there before and I've
been there before and we understand that
it's trapped as we got out of it,
but for the people that are in it,
a lot of times they don't even
understand it's a trap.
They just think it's a good job.
The thing that got dental,
I'm doing really good and I got my own
parking spot.
It's got my name on it.
Just a piece of a heartless shitty
machine that makes money.